muy buenos días es un resultado muy duro
para el gobierno y es muy importante lo
que mencionabas de la provincia de
buenos aires que es un bastión
especialmente fuertes de este peronismo
unificado que representa el frente de
todos la coalición de gobierno además es
un bastión especialmente fuerte para la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner que es quien en 2019 llevó la
mayor cantidad de votos para que ganara
alberto fernández la presidencia el
gobierno acusó el golpe hay que ver qué
va a ser en ese sentido está dando
vuelta una serie de especulaciones ahora
respecto a qué golpe de timón puedes
llegar a dar habrá cambios de gabinete
en el gobierno será un gobierno que se
irá más hacia una política
intervencionista sobre todo el económico
será un gobierno que se dirigirá más a
tratar de captar a sectores que tal vez
se volcaron en las urnas especialmente a
la oposición de juntos por el cambio el
partido originalmente del ex presidente
mauricio macri pero que ahora le ha dado
mucha fuerza al eje al jefe de gobierno
de la ciudad de buenos aires horacio
rodríguez larreta quien fue quien promo
los candidatos de la ciudad maría
eugenia vidal que ganó dentro de juntos
por el cambio y en la provincia de
buenos aires diego santilli que era su
segundo que en la ciudad de buenos aires
él también sale muy fortalecido y
también en la ciudad de buenos aires hay
que mirar a javier me late un candidato
por fuera un nuevo candidato que
representa una forma de liberalismo
bastante extremo contrario al estado que
le fue también muy bien como tercera
fuerza en la ciudad natal yo brevemente
ya para finalizar que dice el presidente
fernández sobre su derrota
pero reconocido que claramente hubo
algunos errores y en el mensaje no está
del todo claro exactamente hacia dónde
van a ir por un lado doblo de incorporar
a aquellos que tal vez no han sabido
escuchar bien pero por otro lado también
le pidió a la militancia que salga a
convencer entonces priorizar a la
escucha o priorizará el convencimiento
de un proyecto propio que están ideando